this one this is one of the wilder ones
i think i've ever i fielded thousands of
questions this is from dylan m where are
you at
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
front row center dude
this is a bit of a longer one but it's
worth it have you ever known someone
that got paid for manual labor with an
item
i.e my dad did a day's work of electric
work and was given a jet ski that he
swore would be four times what i paid
for it once i get it running
[Applause]
the once you get it running's a real
gray area
did he ever get it running
goddamn right he didn't
[Music]
it was inside
[Laughter]
what
how the hell do you get a jet ski in the
basement yeah and why is your mail going
to the basement
[Laughter]
dude
there's no such thing as a garage
basement
listen i know we're just a couple of
dumb yankees but don't try to pull over
eyes there ain't no such thing as a
[ __ ] garage basement he's my little
bigger brother in the garage basement
you know
that's what we do down here gibby and
volley
[Applause]
you guys are off your [ __ ] meds
[Applause]
all right so
[Laughter]
you gotta want we gotta slow you gotta
walk me through this so the jet ski is
in your garage slash basement slash
kitchen what are we
doing it's just a trail it sounds like a
trailer
[Laughter]
it was half in the bedroom
weird thing is we live in an apartment
so i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing
basement means underground though
so you took a jet ski underground
down a flight of stairs
damn jesus christ
in case the basement floods god dammit
yeah let's go jeez that's gonna happen
he's down there doing donuts
feeling where the [ __ ] you been
learn how to do barrel
make sure you've got your lapras over on
though all right safety first
that's what i was thinking did you carry
it down or [ __ ]
[Laughter]
now i think you're amish i don't know
what's going on here
like a pulley system you cranked it down
[Music]
okay but why
why did you put it in the basement i
would like to meet your family's
architect if i possibly could
this is crazy your dad willy wonka i
don't know
is it still there to this day
ah of course the mailman took it
probably told the same guy the same
[ __ ] tell you right now once you get
this thing running once you get it up
out of the basement
it's gonna be worth twice as much i'm
telling you it's gonna be like wave race
on n64 i'll tell you
it's a deep car
go ahead buddy
just needed a spark plug or something
goddamn there's no gas in this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
god damn it dylan i told you check the
gaze
oh dude i'm so confused still
if you have to know that's garbage yeah
yeah yeah
give me a nice round of applause
everybody
also you know
we really breezed over him keeping the
mail on the wave runner in the basement
some things are better left unsaid
[Music]
sounds like a cool dad
this guy's got [ __ ] jet skis
you're smoking weed in the basement next
to a rave run waverunner you're pretty
[ __ ] cool
i take back everything i [ __ ] full
circle on this [ __ ] guy
this guy [ __ ] rules dude
[Laughter]
dude he's getting high next to a jet ski
in a basement that's not in water
think about the levels of cool that is
with a bunch of old bills on it
i ain't paying his power coming he'll
[ __ ] itself
[Laughter]
he sends the jet ski to the power
company once you get this [ __ ] running
i'm telling you right now
huh i'd be like six months worth of
[ __ ] heat [ __ ]
you find any wheat in there you bring
that [ __ ] back
i picture i'm talking to the weed deal
you want to come down look at the jet
ski
she's still down there
move the mail get on it
go ahead
there's a grown man in a basement on a
jet
oh dude
give him a round of applause clap it up
i'm sweating dude that's crazy